with reaction author of the number one
bestseller here's the deal former
council of president trump kellyanne
conway along with former trump white
house chief of staff mark meadows
now this is like a series kellyanne
where the new york times
is going after joe biden he can't run
these policies aren't working
um
they almost kind of deserve to give me
credit and say hannity was right all
along about the guy but i don't see that
day coming because they get pulitzers
for selling nothing but a hoax and a
conspiracy theory and a lie
it's all quite curious and here's my
take it's not just today's poll or last
week's poll or next month's poll it's
that they know that both joe biden and
kamala harris are completely damaged
goods uh democrats are looking past both
of them already looking at 2024. this
guy's been here for a year and a half
sean just a couple months ago we were
told he's fdr he's got the energy look
at him go in his ray-bans he's got the
mental acuity now they're done with him
i think they're worried about what's
going to happen i think they know he
lied
about talking to his son about china
they know that he lied about family
members making money
because they were connected to him and
him taking government planes over abroad
and doing that so they know there's a
storm coming also we're about five or
six weeks away from the one year
anniversary of that deadly chaotic pull
out of a withdrawal from afghanistan
where we left 85 billion dollars worth
of our intelligence and equipment within
the wingspan of china turned over kabul
and afghanistan to the taliban women in
afghanistan have fewer rights now
because we have a female vice president
here who can't even speak correctly so
but they know all of this is coming the
second half of 2022 is going to be even
worse in the first half now the new york
times let me just tell you quickly as a
pollster is notoriously pro-democrat
pro-hillary in 2016 provided in 2020
just quickly in in 2020 they said trump
was going to win montana by 6 he won by
16. they said he was going to win kansas
by 71 by 14. they said joe biden was
going to win ohio by one he lost by
eight he was going to win florida by
three he lost by three the list goes on
and on so their sampling is never really
great it's never really great for
republicans always tell the tourists
biden and it's their poll it's a new
york times poll that says 64 of
democrats want somebody beyond joe biden
in 2024 94
that's basically everyone 94 of
democrats under the age of 30 want
someone other other than joe biden
they're already talking about 2024.
nobody's inviting this guy on the trail
with him
he's done i think he's already been
pushed out he doesn't know it yet kamal
is not a prime candidate neither is
mayor pete neither is elizabeth warren
you know mark i look at who's suffering
the most under these policies a lot of
it tied to the climate climate alarmist
cult
and it's the poor the middle class
people on fixed incomes so much of this
rooted in this idea that well we can
import oil from russia iran venezuela
opec and the saudis
but not produce energy domestically
knowing we have hundreds of years of
supply where we can be self-sufficient
i'm having a hard time understand that
understanding that logic and allowing
gas prices and energy prices and the
price of everything else to go sky high
well made in america is good for energy
as well sean you know that and and when
you look at some of the polls that
kellyanne was referring to one of those
has 13
13 of americans believe that we're
headed in the right direction that's
pretty bad performance for joe biden but
here's here's the interesting thing he
could actually do something about it but
he's playing to the left he's playing to
his donors in california his donors in
new york his donors in boston and what
happens is they want the progressive uh
green energy kind of solutions and yet
what he could do is fast-track drilling
in america uh you know they say well
we've we've
allowed more leases to happen yes they
have but they haven't allowed more
drilling to happen and yet we could we
could lower prices i talked to a guy
just the other day a guy in the tree
business you know he says i'm having to
fill up george is having to fill up his
truck each and every week uh and it's a
reminder a constant reminder that
somebody could do something about it and
his words donald trump did do something
about it it's time that we get him back
in the white house all right same
question exit question for both of you
kellyanne
what do the democrats do in 2024
lose they're going to lose actually i
think donald trump has a better chance
of being the republican nominee
than joe biden has it being the
democratic nominee right now in july of
2022 we've never seen anything like this
no i think they lose and then they argue
with each other um terribly because look
they went backwards we elected barack
obama and then donald trump two
political outsiders who did not have
connections to washington dc per se then
we went backwards with a loch ness
monster of the swamp and i think
democrats will learn the lesson i think
peop people to judge and kamal harris
ruined themselves by being in this
administration right so so mark meadows
who in your mind would be the
replacement
well obviously they're going to lurch to
their left uh you know they're going to
continue you'll hear elizabeth warren's
name a lot more than you have uh listen
we're about kellyanne's right we're
about to enter in to the 60 days of of
blame and shame blame the democrat i
mean blame the republicans blame
everybody but democrats and shame hold
your head low and suggest that you have
nothing to do with this biden
administration because of the results
what we'll ultimately see is uh
joe biden bowing out
and they'll distance themselves and hope
that they can reclaim congress after
they lose it in the midterms here in
just a few months
all right mark meadows kellyanne conway
thank you both hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else